OK, let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0
0.
Forty seven.
A very exciting day in some sense, although
I've not yet identified how.
But people are blowing up the phone lines.
Let's see what's on people's minds, starting
with our caller from the 3 4 7 area code caller
from 3 4 7.
What's your name and where you calling from
today?
Caller from 3:47, are you there?
I am on.
Yes, you are.
Me?
Yes, it is.
Yes, yes.
This is Nick from calling from Brooklyn.
Hey, Nick, what's gone, David?
Good.
Oh, yes.
You're on, Nick, you're on the air, right?
Yeah, just wanted to call obviously huge fan
of the show.
Just wanted to call into it.
Yeah, I just wanted to hear your opinion about
something.
So obviously we've been hearing a lot about
about Trump being compared to Hitler, which
is obviously not the case.
However, you know, kind of looking into the
history for the.
Yes.
Kind of before World War Two as well as after
World War Two.
I think you could make the argument that some
of the ideologies at the time, maybe even
today, kind of closely aligned, I say, to
the kind of to the ideas of the Nazi party
than to a possible possibly come of the US
as communism, that idea.
So kind of going into kind of going into the
America first movement in the thirties and
forties, as well as denouncing Japanese as,
you know, less the lesser race during the
Pacific campaign and then obviously sheltering
Nazi officials post-World War 2.
So just want to kind of hear your opinion
on that and how that maybe plays into what's
going on today.
Yeah.
I mean, I think you're the we don't really
need to do the sort of hyperbolic sensationalists
thing of saying Trump is like Hitler to have
a conversation about similarities in pre-World
War Two, Germany.
Yeah.
You know how Donald Trump.
Donald Trump's tendency.
So when you look at the use of hyper nationalism
to justify policy, when you look at the othering
of certain groups that Donald Trump has identified,
it's been it's ranged, it's been everything
from Mexicans with the whole many, you know,
rapists and all that stuff, Muslims from the
Middle East, Asian folks in different ways.
When you look at the sort of attitude towards
media that Donald Trump espouses in a free
press, there are definite similarities.
So, you know, when you look at somebody like
Timothy Snyder has written a lot about this,
you don't have to say Trump is like Hitler.
I have no reason to think right now that Trump
is, you know, looking to exterminate Jews
or any other particular group in the way that
Hitler wanted to.
But there are many similarities between what
we see now and re-record or to Germany.
And it's perfectly reasonable to talk about
them.
Signs of totalitarianism, authoritarianism.
Right, right.
And I think just talking about you kind of
the disbelief that that coming communism or
socialism, you know, is the big evil.
Going back to the 40s.
You know where it was the big evil compared
to, you know, kind of cozying up to the Nazi
beliefs, especially in America.
I think it was kind of a dangerous train of
thought.
And I can definitely see that still happening
today in terms of the way that the Reich portrays
communism as well as socialism.
Not really knowing the difference between
them.
Yes.
So that's just basically why I wanted to call
him.
All right.
For context, I am I'm German, so I'm U.S.
born but raised in Germany.
Go.
Yes.
I was kind of an interesting viewpoint on
that, but.
But.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Thanks for taking.
Thanks for taking my call and all the best.
All right.
Great to hear from you, Nick from Brooklyn.
6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 is, of course, the number.